my first question is around you talking
about men chasing Excellence being the
best versions of themselves
um but in that pursue obviously we Face
mental health challenges I think just
about everybody you know nobody's on a
swift linear path to success right
there's challenges that you face and
some people face more challenges than
others and I wanted to know firstly your
take on mental health and how do men
overcome mental health challenges on
their pursuit to happiness and success
yeah so on on that path to happiness and
success and doing all that work there's
going to be a lot more failures than the
well-be wins so I think framing it
correctly and making sure it's
understood uh so that that guy that
wants to go and let's say start the
business and put a little dent in the
universe understands that there are
going to be way more failures than there
are successes
um reading biographies from successful
entrepreneurs I would recommend that you
know as a starting place so you
understand all the failures that got in
the way of the success everybody sees a
somebody that's successful and they say
oh he's an overnight success or
something like that but the truth of the
matter is every overnight success I know
took usually about a decade of work and
within that decade failure after failure
pivot after pivot
um I think a lot of young men today have
this preconceived notion that you know
it's a linear line
uh but it's very squiggly and it goes
all over the place and sometimes you're
up and sometimes you're down and dealing
with rejection is a skill that you need
to get good at being a strategist is a
skill that need to be good at
um so you know learning those skills
young and making sure that you infuse
them into the fabric of your being will
get you there sooner than you think
why do you think it is that maybe it's
just a perception or maybe it's coming
out it's difficult to say it right but
why do you think that younger men and
the newer Generations tend to face more
mental health challenges than
were in older Generations well we've
become a society of weaker softer men
haven't we
um the you know the generation that my
dad grew up in and my granddad grew up
in was tough
um there were boundaries there was
disciplines there was spanking still you
know at that time we're now raising a
generation of entitled soft men
um I call this phenomenon the
pussification of the West if you know we
can use that term because essentially
you have weaker softer men with lower
testosterone than they did several
decades ago
um it's it's a combination of nurture
and nature
um society and culture
softens men to the extent that you know
we've all not all but seventy percent of
the population essentially fell for a
scam demic a few years ago we stood on
dots we wore face diapers we took
experimental Jabs thinking that we need
to do all these things to save the
planet uh when in reality and in
hindsight when all the data was released
and the evidence was presented it was no
more dangerous than the common cold
yeah
I think just sticking on that topic of
mental health firstly right I think
from my understanding what I believe it
is is
the society has drastically changed okay
the vast majority of society now you
don't see many people going out to bars
and clubs as you used to you don't see
people out as much as you used to and
the reason is is because everybody's on
these little devices right and in this
interactive world and that's increasing
as time goes on
so that's one aspect of it and I think
we have this delusion of what we think
you know other people's lives are and
then we reflect that on ourselves so I
think that's one aspect of it but I
think another aspect is we have a lot
more free time on our hands now and I
think back in the you know olden days
people were working a lot harder they
were more into their purpose and their
mission and you know because they didn't
have a choice like you had a family to
feed you know and if you go back a bit
more further down the generations you
know if you had to go down the road and
go get a bucket of water to bring that
back I mean the last thing that's going
to be on your mind is you know things
you know reminiscing in your brain about
a woman or whatever it is that's on your
mind so I think
essentially we mental health is
something that we not all the time
because there can't be physical issues
as well with regards to the levels of
chemicals that we have in our body and
the hormones that you know everybody's
different but barring that I do think we
get in our own way a lot nowadays and I
think that some of the issues that face
younger men is one obviously you discuss
there about lower testosterone levels
and I have found that not just myself
but people around me and everybody I've
spoken to if I'm not training if I fall
off my routine in the gym
I will automatically start to feel down
and I'll start to not feel that same
rigor and that same energetic
um I won't be my energetic self anymore
and that's the bottom line yeah like I
said there's there's a lot of different
attack vectors that are softening men
um social media is just example of one
of hundreds
um you know somebody's social media feed
on Instagram is a highlight reel of
their best moments in life I've said
this many times because you see um
parents especially moms on Facebook do
this where they'll post the most perfect
picture of their children look at my two
angels but they'll never post the
picture of Billy and Nancy beating the
living crap out of each other in the
back seat where Billy smashes his ice
cream cone over his sister's head that
never gets shared but that's but that's
the reality of about probably 98 of her
life there's only very short moments
that you see shared on social media that
are absolutely perfect or look perfect
and a lot of the times they're not
perfect and they have to touch them up
with Photoshop or something like that or
filter so you have to understand that
these things aren't real they have been
presented to you as real but they're
manipulated truths and the word the
world is a lot harder and and tougher
than what you think it is
like I said you know older Generations
had it harder you know like kids today
don't have chores they don't have to cut
the lawn parents will hire lawn care
companies I remember pushing around the
lawnmower when I was about seven or
eight years old right like this is this
is Things That You Don't See children do
anymore because you know Mom or Dad
don't want to force them to do it or if
mom or dad are divorced they don't want
to be the one that bees you know this is
a bad parent because then they'll run to
the other parent and make a big fuss
about it so there's a lot of things
happening out there like I said there's
a lot of different attack vectors that
are softening men we could spend hours
discussing them all but it's a reality
of today's world right
100 you just brought back some memories
with the uh with the lawnmower I
remember having to take that lawnmower
around and the wire getting chopped and
my dad really disciplining me but we
don't get that anymore right yeah you're
not saying about that today anymore no
no that's how you learn but I I never
understood when I was young about doing
the small things I don't know I've got
an elder brother and my eldest brother
would always you know he'd take me to
the boxing gym he would whoop my butt
you know he would he would teach me how
to assemble things and it's not until
later years in my life that I started to
see the the value of these things going
to the gym learning how to train I took
it for grinding I thought I wasted a lot
of time early on learning how to train
how to exercise being involved in boxing
so on and so forth but in later life you
start to see the valuable lessons yeah I
think combat combat sex and hunting are
probably the three most natural things
and I don't use the word feeling that
often when I talk he was thinking when I
discuss topics but I think as a man when
it comes to sex hunting and fighting
those three things feel very very
natural it's infusing fabric of our DNA
and combat is something that's been
taken away from us even in Boy Scouts
like when I was a kid we used to play
this game British Bulldog where you know
essentially you'd line up on each end of
the field and you just charge and RAM
the crap out of each other sort of thing
they don't allow that anymore because
children will be hurt you know they're
afraid of what the lawyers will do I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out